was wäre denn ein möglicher kompromiss
herr mählich bzw sein staatspräsident
sagt ganz klar die russischen truppen
wieder komplett raus ja zu der linie die
wir eben vor dem 24 februar diesen
jahres hatten freilich haben ist ja da
bleibt der zankapfel krimmer stillstehen
und die krim zu versorgen dafür ist der
landweg offensichtlich nötig so habe ich
das alles verstanden was ich im letzten
acht jahren wahrgenommen habe und dafür
auch immer der name mario puls und der
die frage die sich mir stellt ist wie
soll die verhandlungslösung aus den
offensichtlich werden die europäer nach
verschiedenen aktionen letzten acht
jahren von putin nicht ernst genommen
das kann man mögen oder nicht mögen das
scheint eine tatsache zu sein wenn sich
das so verhält ist die frage wie kriegt
man die amerikaner und die russen an den
tisch weil offensichtlich diebe leute in
washington von ihm ernster genommen
werden also wäre ich der meinung dass
wir in europa versuchen mit den
amerikanern gemeinsam eine
verhandlungslösung mit der ukraine und
den russen auf die reihe zu bringen das
problem wird der zankapfel grimm bleiben
und das ist nun mal über 30 jahre
aufgebaut es gab damals und ich hab das
ja den 980 alles gerne verfolgt weil ich
das so spannend und wichtig fand weil
sich die ganze welt geändert hat für
mich es gab damals das versprechen dass
die nato nicht erwartet wird also vorher
man auch wenn sie kämen ergeben das wird
doch das werden die frage wenn die
brennweite bei den russen bleibt haben
sie das problem dass der landtag nicht
da ist es bleibt ein zankapfel
sie beenden den krieg nicht wie sie die
sicherheitsstruktur für europa einig wie
sieht die gemeinsame sicherheitsstruktur
für europa aus
wir müssen schauen dorthin also wo die
wurzeln dieses übels liegt ja das ist
leider in moskau und und es geht um ein
regime ein faschistisches regime das
sich etabliert hat in russland es geht
nicht nur um die person boten wir hoffen
dass diese dieser staatsmann bald nicht
mehr da ist aber wir wissen nicht was
danach kommt und das heißt wir müssen
uns gedanken machen also mit mit mit der
zukunft dieses staates ist und was wir
sollten wir die diese 80 prozent der
russen erreichen die sie sind durch die
baganda sie sind die berater müssen an
der stelle irgendwie rdx wurden in den
letzten acht jahren seit der krämer sie
müssen an der stelle auf jedes wort
aufpassen frau hermenau macht eine aus
ihrer sicht wie sie es formuliert
kompromisslinie auf weil sie ganz
nüchtern und natürlich aus ganz anderen
perspektive darauf
consult seit vier monaten dieser krieg
das müssen wir irgendwie realistisch
einordnen wir sehen was auf der krim
passiert ist gibt es mittlerweile auch
aus ihrer sicht solche kompromisslinien
oder müssen sie ganz hart bleiben müssen
sie unsere position vom 24 das nämlich
alles frei von russischen truppen sein
muss das gilt bis heute schauen sie das
ziel das erste ziel bleibe dass die
britischen truppen sich zurückziehen
status quo ante 24 verbraucht das ist
das allererste was danach kommt das ist
das ist die sache die natürlich
weiterhin im raum steht dafür müssen die
präsidentin verhandeln können putin
verweigert das gespräch und das ist
klasse vielleicht die zweite etappe aber
zuerst einmal ist das ziel das für alle
klar sein sollte die ukraine gewinnt
wenn die russen sie sich zurück sorgen
und ich kann hier nur ein beispiel sagen
die russen haben über 125.000
quadratkilometer besetzt seit diesen 109
tagen krieg das heißt das wäre ein
fünftel ein fünftel der kranken ukraine
oder in mitteldeutschland und meine
frage an sie was würden sie opfern
würden sie ihre heimat der menschen
bevor man opfern oder brandenburg oder
wurde sagte seine spaß machen die opfer
um
eine frage der geschichte die eine
geschichte ist die deutschen haben
damals den franzosen das elsass
angeboten damit sie nach dem ersten
weltkrieg vertrauen finden dass die
deutschen keinen krieg wieder machen und
das zweite angebot war die ddr
wir wollten schon mal abgegeben
und was heißt das konkret auf die frage
von ein wenig wenn er sei jetzt würde
sie jetzt die hinter den erstellt die
damals ddr die eltern meine mutter
erzählt die älteren konnten nicht
aussuchen was sie es so haben wollten
warum was was ist was spricht dagegen
dass man bei lohans grund dann jetzt
dafür dass damit der abstand aber nach
verstehen sie sollte das schweizer sind
erst okkupiert und würden sie sagen ok
damit er nicht jetzt weiter nach freund
und nein das sieht das eigentliche
frage ist doch mein am 1
lassen sie doch die bevölkerung in
lohans grund das selber abstimmen
richtig leben sie doch die möglichkeit
den leuten demokratisch abzustimmen was
sie wollen ist nicht die möglichkeit
dass die rosa gilt das leider gehen ja
das ist nicht meine welt krieg aufhört
nun wollen auch der krieg aufhört
nach vier monaten glauben sie an die
nach krieg nach vier monaten ja
bombenterror dort glaubens aber er weiß
dass es jetzt lange nicht es gäbe also
die demokratie dort glauben in denen ich
glaube dass die menschen die hand ich
habe selber erlebt ich war nur 1 8 auf
der straße und ich weiß dass die
menschen auch in verschiedenen
situationen durchaus in der lage sind
auch für sich selber entscheidungen zu
treffen der punkt auf die nicht mehr
weiter kam etwas vorhin von etwas früher
vor der hofreiter hat gesagt wir über
william ende nicht auf der falschen
seite stehen so haben sie heute auch
intoniert am anfang auf der falschen
seite des events das werden wir dann
bewerten müssen ja das ist am anfang und
in den lauf der dinge nicht immer klar
sie haben hier einmal diskussion
ausgemacht die nur auf moralischen
vorstellungen was hier die kommt in
europa gut an weil man nämlich gerne
verteidigen möchte wie man lebt und wie
man ist aber wer unter unterstrich wenn
wirklich die amerikaner und die europäer
indien china alle anderen haben andere
vorstellungen bei der urabstimmung hat
man das gesehen wer sich alles enthalten
hat also das ist eine situation zwischen
russland und der ukraine auf der einen
seite und den europäern und amerikanern
auf der anderen seite die ihm das sagen
in ihrem fernsehen das ist ein
europäischer krieg also das heißt die
frage wie die sicherheitsarchitektur in
europa aussehen muss ist relevant das
war und wenn wir uns alle passieren sehr
offene mit allen mitteln ausgetragenen
diskussionen die diskussion die im
moment in deutschland es genau gibt
hermeling macht ihnen diese diskussion
ein bisschen angst kann die zur gefahr
werden für den krieg in der ukraine für
sie
tut mir einfach leid das ja dass diese
debatte man hat immer trump als als
feindbild gehabt all die jahre und ich
musste zusehen wie er dann hat das
america first prinzip für kritisiert
wurde aber das was jetzt auch sie
teilweise heute vortragen ist dasselbe
germany first also wir wollen unseren
wohlstand sichern und wir wollen uns
keine gedanken machen wir müssen ja
unterstützen wenn wir das aber das geht
ja gut für mich das und das ist legitim
das ist ihre entscheidung wie können sie
nicht zwingen uns zu hell das geht nicht
und wohlstand das geht darum ihnen auch
hier sie wollen eine bilderserie es geht
auch um das
recht geht die bereiche dieses zeichen
ja genau so ist und
ja und das ist aber deswegen müssen wir
auch er ich bin dankbar für die
diskussion weil wir endlich sind mit
ernannte sie sagen was ihnen schmerz und
ich verstehe sie und ich sage ihnen was
unserer sorgen sind und dass wir immer
noch auf ihre hilfe angewiesen sind und
wir hoffen dass deutschland diesen
beitrag leistet und es geht eben darum
ob diese solidarität nur eine floskel
ist ein lippenbekenntnis oder mehr ein
poltern und heute dieser frage was es
geht nicht nur um was es geht auch um
das soziale jungs denkt man sagen war es
nicht auch um die kollegen chris vorholt
und dann müssen wir ja ich wollte gar
noch sagen das geht ja gar nicht nur um
unsere 1200 arbeitsplätze die
interessieren natürlich kein großartig
aber wenn wir nicht wirtschaftlich sind
und unser unternehmen steht dann stehen
ganz viele andere unternehmen dann gehen
ganz viele bankrottgehen
straßenbauunternehmen pleite dann gehen
die firma um uns rum pleite als fliegt
nicht ein flughafen vom br ohne unseren
spritzen da fliegt auch kein privatjet
mehr
selten vom br vielen dank für diese
tatsächlich sehr offene diskussion
schlusswort soll bei uns vitali
klitschko haben in dieser runde
baukonzern hat heute das interview mit
ihm geführt und hat die frage gestellt
was wünschen sie sich einen spaß mit
putin passiert sein wunsch ist diese
antwort
oder muss gehen oder muss verschwinden
oder muss zum
sport musik und müsse die
liebe gott soll ihn zu sich holen sagt
vitali klitschko